midi dans la banlieue de tunis
nous sommes au lycée français
l'heure est au recueillement
ces victimes innocentes
et leurs familles meurtries
monsieur vasseur le proviseur s'adresse
au nom de la france à ses élèves pour la
majorité tunisiens vivre la démocratie
aujourd'hui il veut être solidaire unie
face à la terreur
responsables dans ces moments difficiles
aujourd'hui
défendons la liberté la dignité la
justice et l'ordre aujourd'hui
défendons la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité
aujourd'hui nous sommes bardot nous
sommes la tunisie
[Applaudissements]
fait exceptionnel le proviseur va
autoriser ces adolescents a chanté
l'hymne de la tunisie dans ce lieu
symbole de la république française
[Applaudissements]
en quoi c'était important pour moi sur
10 ge ge dans cet état moi je ne suis
que le reflet ta volonté des élèves dès
lors qu'il ya comme ça 1500 élèves qui
ont envie de manifester leur désaccord
que pour des heures ne peut bien sûr que
les suivre et faire en sorte que
l'europe depuis s'exprimer comme il
l'entend borek une jeunesse meurtrie et
inquiète le terrorisme est à nos portes
avant il était
avec astrid maintenant ils sont à
l'arrêt la vraie capitale dont tous jour
au lendemain ils peuvent nous attaquer
comment ça que ça avance pas
processus démocratique va dalton
repartir
il est 12h vin à l'horloge de l'avenue
bourguiba en tunisie
le temps semble s'être arrêté il y à 24
heures exactement
hier alors que le musée du bardo et
rempli de touristes plusieurs hommes
armés font un carnage
20 morts et 47 blessés
au même moment dans le bâtiment voisin
l'assemblée nationale débattaient d'un
projet de loi sur le terrorisme
ce défi au processus démocratique
tunisien a été revendiqué aujourd'hui
par l'organisation état islamique avec
les victimes et avec les tunisiens nous
avons vécu le jour d'après
mounir el salam et journalistes le nom
de son émission sur la route elle est
diffusée sur la télévision tunisienne et
elle n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom
hier vers midi alors qu'il filme près du
musée du bardo il voit passer près de
lui ses voitures de police 1 il ne le
sait pas encore mais il va être le seul
à avoir filmé ce moment là
les j'ai eu la chance moment qu'ils
étaient là pour filmer il ya eu quelques
pêcheurs qui sont
c'était de gérer il y avait foule et ses
montées
voilà voilà fall il avait entendu des
coups de feu bien sûr c'était un moment
dit en princesse kaguya fans
à l'intérieur la tuerie est en cours
les touristes qui le peuvent se
précipite vers la sortie
deux terroristes sont tués par les
forces de sécurité tunisiennes un
suspect est arrêté par la police
cette peine vous unir la filmer ou de
fous de là bas parce que
quelqu un temps soupçonné de donner des
informations ont été attrapés par les
flics idem pour tout le monde
parmi les victimes des français deux
sont morts et 700 blessés
[Applaudissements]
michel vauzelle vice président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'assemblée nationale et grand ami de la
tunisie est venu spécialement pour
soutenir les familles à l'hôpital
charles nicolle il se rend au chevet de
ses deux touriste originaire d'orléans
toutes deux semblent très choqué
dans ce musée elles ont vécu
l'inimaginable la mère de cette femme
est entre la vie et la mort
[Musique]
donc on reste
là il ya une personne qui
8 ou les arabes qui a été atteinte si
donc raconter ce qui s'est passé
était toute contente de venir
vous poser un peu
elle est au par doc et de musées survie
verts ont leurs amis des petites
usine de tapis des petites choses là
pour qu'elle soit protégée toute leur
vie puis voilà surtout l'art ce gars par
un affreux pour lui le salut mon médecin
david wood usines les gens qui mouraient
autour d'elle ou c'est assez évident
c'est choquant impensable
les l'une d'elles heurter une colonne
elle est tombée c'est ce qui l'a sauvé
parce qu'elle n'a pas la marée de sang
étaient là ils sont allés un peu mieux
il y avait des bousculades sa durée
ensemble c
enquête
[Musique]
dans les couloirs nous apercevons une
touriste grièvement blessé
trois de ses compatriotes japonais sont
tombés sous les balles des terroristes
toute la journée la tunisie compte ses
morts
saïd aïdi ministre de la santé depuis 24
heures il met à jour la liste des
victimes 44
patients qui ont été admis hier dans
certains sont sortis en a sept qui sont
déjà sortant il y en a deux qui sont
dans une situation critique un
malheureusement qui est décédé de
nationalité française et mon adresse
donc ont mené en sera à sa famille ça
s'est passé quand il est il a été admis
à l'hôpital dans un état critique
vraiment très très très grave et il est
décédé hier soir à 21h40
mais parfois au milieu de l'horreur une
bonne nouvelle
hier ces deux espagnols étaient portées
disparues
ils viennent d'être retrouvés après
avoir passé la nuit caché dans le musée
la femme est enceinte de quatre mois
je suis très content de vous voir hier
j'ai vu votre photo et aujourd'hui je
vous vois j'en suis très heureux
le garçon
gentil sourire comme celle-là on à
cerizay
[Musique]
reconnu comme étant victimes elles se
sont réfugiés par leurs propres moyens
hier reprise parole de panique et voilà
donc
un événement heureux puisque
la dame est enceinte de quatre points et
que le bébé est une petite fille se
portent bien mort c'est quelque part un
message symboliquement d'espoir
alors que les hôpitaux soignent les
blessés
moment solennel
pour la première fois de l'histoire du
pays le président de la république
tunisien réuni le conseil de sécurité
avec lui aujourd'hui les responsables de
la police et de l'armée
une réunion au sommet pour cette jeune
démocratie
devant ses ministres le président
affirme que le pays est en guerre
face au terrorisme
le porte-parole de la présidence
assume un discours martial
si si c'est totalement confidentielles
on peut pas filmer personne n'y a aucune
caméra à l'intérieur
exceptionnel qui démontre des signes
la tunisie
et en état de guerre contre le
terrorisme
ces courants 16 heures de réunion
exceptionnelle
et on la première fois et vous savez
quelles sont les décisions qui vont
prendre au niveau sécurité c'est quelque
chose qui va être un très très haut
niveau ce sera un message fort ce sera
un message fort ce sera des mesures
exceptionnelles et nous avons beaucoup
autant sur la mobilisation des tunisiens
que sur la mobilisation internationale
pour se soutenir la tunisie dans cette
épreuve qu'elle traverse
près du musée du bardo ce soir un
rassemblement contre le terrorisme et
pour la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
malgré le choc de l'attentât le peuple
tunisien donne de la voix pour tenter de
préserver les premiers pas de la
démocratie dans ce pays du maghreb
[Applaudissements]